Islam
[Music]
requirements
so like what is the thing that is
stopping you if I ask you
what is the thing that you think is
helping you to become Muslim my friend
my family your family okay just to give
you advice because my wife is a Rivers
she's solution she's Absolution of
Italian yeah she became Muslim when she
was 14. yeah
so basically she she said one thing did
not make sense to her of course she went
to school but one thing makes sense to
her that if Jesus Is God how he was
praying to God yeah exactly no make
sense to her so she was she went to
school her family took her to a
different school so the school she was
before there was no law of Muslims so
when she took her to different School a
mom and her father for a stepfather she
started mixing with the Muslims and they
started saying I used to believe in
Jesus however I believe God is perfect
we don't believe she is to be God we
don't believe Prophet Muhammad to be God
we believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of Allah we believe Jesus was
the message of Allah and the Messiah he
understand so it makes sense to her so
what you have to understand sister and
Islam teach us in the Quran even if your
parents even if your parents are
disbelievers you still respect them take
care of them however there's priorities
that when you die your parents love you
so much no doubt that I will not be of
you inside the Greek they will put you
inside the grave and they will leave you
that's what Allah said in the Quran
Arabic then translated
on the day of judgment when the father
was will flee from his son the mother
will flee from her daughter everyone
will say must serve myself today
understand so don't let your parents
watch your sister watch sorry sorry
don't let your parents love you to
accept the truth if it makes sense to
you it's the truth I mean I don't know
how would you if you don't mind asking
you're 20. I'm saying look you're like
[Music]
I don't want to go in details she had a
problem with her parents okay
alhamdulillah afterwards I got married
to her correct it's a funny story
because her mother she wants to kill me
she said yes I'm gonna catch this guy in
Bush anyway I said to my wife once let's
go visit your mom
outside London that day was raining at
the when he went to the house she told
me how I treated my wife that's why it's
true sometimes actions is louder than
words you know when she told me how I
treat my wife even how I treated her
respectfully she loves me now she said
she always called my wife said tell my
son to come you see well alhamdulillah
because Allah opened those for you but
since they have to be stronger because
you are you are your own existence
everything within you is from God
understand let me give you example
imagine you're in a house may Allah
forbid and there's a fire everywhere
and you're about to die you try your
best you try your best to serve yourself
and I came and I saved your life
what would you say to me
would you remember me all the time
of course I saved your life then I said
you know what shamsi but sister I never
gave you a life so why don't you
remember and
pray to the one who gave your life for
free
understand you know if you notice if I
saved your life you never you didn't say
let me ask something do you beat up your
wife you kill people you you thank me
straight away because I saved something
very dear to you what about God will
give you everything who gave you eyes
everything you know you know I was
asking this gentleman a question why
Islams think spreading and guess what
that is in the Quran Allah said
[Music]
it's Allah who sent his Prophet Muhammad
with the truth and Islam in order for
Islam to overpower all the religions
even if the enemies Islam dislike it now
we know there is a huge war against
Islam there's a huge war against Islam
but guess what the fastest growing of
the face of the earth is what is them so
who's doing the job
I know
let me give you examples I saw for
taking your time thank you very much for
giving your time let me tell you
something about why we believe Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger Allah and why
Islam is very special and Islam
distinguished from any way of life or
religion when it comes to Islam Islam
came to preserve fight things and I
wanted to pay attention to it yeah Islam
came to preserve five things Islam came
to preserve religion what does that mean
worshiping God Alone
paganism atheism policism is forbidden
worshiping Allah alone is very very
important because Allah alone you start
following the desires all right that's
the first one the ones of Allah secondly
Islam came to preserve intellect can't
preserve what intellect that's what
alcohol and drugs is forbidden thirdly
Islam came to preserve wealth wealth
that's why
gambling and interest is forbidden
fourthly Islam came to preserve marriage
families Heritage lineage that's what
fornication adultery is forbidden lastly
Islam came to preserve life that's why
committing suicide killing people and
Justice is forbidden this first thing
that Islam came to preserve nor just
came to preserve them also there's a
barrier punishment for anyone to break
them why because if we do break these
five Necessities we'll corrupt our
society let me ask you alcohol is it
good for us
[Music]
gambling is it good or bad yes bad thank
you collectively and individually
interest is bad why interest is bad make
the rich richer poor poorer interest is
a type of manipulation Islam teach us if
you're my sister in Islam you are in
need of money I will give you money I
will not utilize your need to tell you
listen I'm gonna give you 5 000 but give
me back 10 000 because I know when
you're desperate you will accept any
condition instead rather I said look
sister this is the help what you do you
can give it back to me if you don't if
you don't may Allah forgive me
so likewise what fornication destroy
families so these five and all of these
things goes back to the most evil thing
which is when it's in a way from your
creator
but I'll tell you something there is
some people do benefit from these vices
alcohol gambling interest who are they
majority of science those who are in
power that's why those who are in power
majority of times they are very hostage
Islam because they're rich they make
Islam look bad through the media by
using their money even though Islam is
good for us individually and
collectively the question we should ask
ourselves how a man Prophet Muhammad
existed 1 000 400 years ago in the
middle of desert he couldn't read or
write he came who did the perfect way of
life because it was what message of
Allah doesn't make sense
that's what I will say to you you know I
always said to people
the imaginary cake big cake front of you
all of it what will happen to you
maybe you got sick before that your
vomits yeah in order for you to feel the
sweetness of the cake what do you do
take it bit by bit likewise it's done
step by step the first most important
pillar is
shared us the two testimony bear witness
there's no one worthy of worship Allah
that's how you become Muslim Prophet
Muhammad
all has sins Is Forgiven then step by
step you start learning and what I will
say to you
if you die and you know you don't accept
Islam don't blame you no one except
yourself because Allah based upon his
Mercy create Paradise based upon his
anger create the halfway however he gave
you free will to choose to follow or
reject by your parents is not a valid
excuse before you create her to not
accept Islam you don't have to repair
the away what you can do is
better
that's a good question but you don't
have Arabic to become Muslim I know yeah
step by step for example
that's what I said to you there Islam
yes so the first pillar is that
professing and accepting o Allah human
Lord I should worship you alone and I
believe the message of Allah of course
the prayer and charity believe in the
Angels The Messengers all of them now
when you accept that then step by step
you start learning now if you have to
pray you don't
[Music]
if you don't know it then you learn it
then you start praying you don't have to
pray straight away what I'm saying is
let me give you example if you want to
learn how to drive a car do you land
inside the car or outside the car
inside the car and to sit on the car
what you need a key and that key that
you need to learn more is that is the
key called share the 10.
so don't let this stop you because Allah
is the most merciful you know may Allah
forbid if you become Muslim now
even though you haven't played
in the stand even though you haven't
played but you said the most important
thing because the first message that
Allah gave to Jesus Moses Abraham is
alive at the time of Jesus
[Music]
is the message of Allah now the last
prophet is Muhammad Muslim
[Music]
I'm standing at the dollar table
preaching she came and she was asking a
question
then I spoke to her she became Muslim
after that English guy became Muslim too
and before that a Romanian guy became
Muslim so anyway remember I'll show you
well let me show you that
I'll show you the lion let me show you
this guy
my dear brothers and sisters as you know
we are we have a campaign to raise the
money for our Masjid or to buy a new
place because as you know the current
place that we have behind the market
subhanallah I believe you did see or if
you haven't seen it yet go back to our
channel does that works and see it the
place is very terrible but like it's
very hard to walk through it's not safe
for women or children to come so we are
raising money we haven't found a place
yet but what happened we are raising
money because what happened in the past
if you don't find if you do find the
place we don't have enough money for
deposits so we raise and manage a lot
while we are still looking for a new
place so make sure you have us may Allah
bless you
[Music]
doesn't make sense to me I'm reading
Quran about Islam I find it peace and
it's making sense to me so he said you
know what our new decision must be the
truth and he becomes them
and you say it yeah it becomes Muslim as
well
you know sister in Islam teach us
if someone becomes if you become Muslim
today I don't know what will happen to
the Future I'll take that you know what
we do we pray of course there are some
things he mentioned in the past he
himself he admits he was wrong I
understand because Islam teach us to
take care of our wives take care of our
sisters take care of our daughters
especially specially our mothers
[Music]
except that how many people left the
houses they never come back how many
people won't sleep they never wake up
this is the reality that's what Allah
threatened his enemies with death
because you go to bed so if you make
sense to his clothes you should becomes
then you learn step by step say share
that's it if you do that if you do that
may Allah forbid you will go to German
y
are you guys still tomorrow
and think about it imagine you die today
and you stand before Allah and he said
to you why he did not accept Islam
what's a reason you think you will say
it to Allah and you think will be valid
well except shaytan and let me ask you
if you know someone is your worst enemy
would you follow him
under pressure or something no you know
many times you do evil things up in
front of everyone you're gonna accept
the truth You're Gonna Worship your
creator the one you've been cutting off
but Allah it's better off to become
Muslim today when you leave
alhamdulillah and I've been doing this
for 15 years never it's my brother
because they're with me all the time I
will tell you never someone except Islam
and he came back said you know what
brother
earlier
he's a river
he became Muslim when he was 17.
I understand
you stuff you know that you have no
excuse you have no reason for not
accepting Islam Today
forget the cameras okay cameras like I'm
not assuming anything about it
as well no no forget cameras houses look
what is your friend left you something
yeah
just come come